[Music]
laughs I would say
Zorro okay I'm not I'm not
big fan of the robot he I think he's
like Zorro this is close it's not a hero
a villain but I think about sometimes
it's a bit of a leprechaun he's he's
very tricky very clever and he's you
know he always gets gets out of tough
spots in tough situations though somehow
I don't know why but I just I somehow I
sometimes I picture was like a big you
know green hat I know he's not Irish or
anything but like Aronian Runyan is like
some guy who tries to pretend his boots
but he is definitely not maybe this guy
from the usual suspects yeah Keyser söze
Joker Joker the truck oh well he would
say that the Joker - okay he has to be
the Joker right there has everyone said
the Joker I just thought the laughs is
they have a really similar laugh I would
rather be a Whelan I mean there are two
villains that I really like
one is the Joker and his fun-loving man
another one is Lord Shen from Kolkata
so these are my favorites while the the
goodie goods are not that attraction to
me
[Music]